KURTIS VAN GENT: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Connecting to
Cloud SQL from Kubernetes.
My name is Kurtis Van Gent.
I'm a Developer
Programs Engineer.
I work on Google Cloud
Platform to make the developer
experience better for
developers like you.
Today, we're going to be
talking about how to connect
to Cloud SQL from Kubernetes.
We're going to have
three main points.
The first is we're
going to cover
how to connect to
Cloud SQL in general,
then we're going to narrow
down and talk about connecting
from Kubernetes to Cloud SQL.
And then finally, we're going
to narrow down even more
and do a hands-on example
of the best practices
for connecting from Kubernetes.
Before we begin,
there's some basics
that you should understand
before we start.
First, it's expected that you
know and understand Cloud SQL
and how a managed
database works,
what some of the benefits are,
and when you should try and use
one.
Second, it's understood
that you should understand
the basics of a container,
how container images work,
and what some of the benefits
for containerization are.
And finally, we hope
that you understand
some of the basics, at
least, of Kubernetes
and you understand some concepts
such as pod and deployments.
First, let's talk about
connecting to Cloud SQL.
When you're connecting,
there's two different things
you need to think about.
First, the path-- how am I
going to reach the instance?
And the second is
authorization--
how do I get permission
to talk to the instance?
When you're selecting a path,
you have two different options.
The first option is public IP.
Public IP is a
static IPv4 address
that's accessible from
the public internet.
As long as you have
access to the internet,
you can potentially connect
to your Cloud SQL instance.
By default, authorization
is required,
since we don't want
anyone connecting
to your application that
has access to the internet.
Some of the benefits
of public IP
is that you can connect
from outside GCP,
while one of the drawbacks
is you may have higher
latency, since you're connecting
over the internet instead
of using an internal network.
The second option you have is
to connect using private IP.
Private IP is an
IPv4 address that's
peered into your project via a
Virtual Private Cloud or VPC,
for short.
By default, authorization
is not required,
but you do have to be on the
VPC to access your Cloud SQL
instance.
One of the benefits
of private IP
is you usually
have lower latency.
This is because you're not
connecting over the internet
and instead connecting directly
through an internal network.
Once you've decided
how to connect,
the next step is authorization.
When it comes to
authorization, there's
three different options
you have to look at.
The first is the
Cloud SQL Proxy.
The Cloud SQL Proxy
is a binary that
provides IAM authentication.
It uses a service
account to provide
authorization and
strong encryption using
short-lived SSL certificates.
The second option you can
use is authorized networks.
This is where you specify
a list of IP addresses
that are authorized to connect.
For private IP, there
is a similar feature
called VPC egress firewall
rules that you can use instead.
The third option is
self-managed SSL.
You can create SSL certificates
for your instance that
can be distributed to
your application that
encrypt your connections.
For MySQL and Postgres,
this is a client
and server-side credential,
while for SQL Server,
this is only a
server-side credential.
It's important to
remember that these are
options for authorization only.
You still have to authenticate
with the database using
your username the password.
So to summarize,
you have private IP
and you have public IP.
For public IP, you have to
use either the Cloud SQL
Proxy or authorized networks.
We also recommend that if you
are using authorized networks,
that you use self-managed SSL.
This encrypts your
data and makes
sure that no one else can
read it in transit unless they
have the certificates.
However, this is automatically
done by the Cloud SQL Proxy,
so if you decide to
use it, you won't
have to worry about
managing your own SSL.
When it comes to
public versus private,
use whichever one works best.
And for authorization, while we
recommend the Cloud SQL Proxy,
it's perfectly OK to
use authorized networks
and self-managed SSL as well.
Next, let's talk about
Kubernetes to Cloud SQL.
There are three different ways
that you're going to see people
recommending you to connect.
The first is you can connect
directly using private IP.
The second is you can run
the proxy as a service.
And finally, you can run
the proxy as a sidecar.
This is our recommended
solution over the first two.
Because private IP doesn't
require any authorization,
it's possible to just
connect directly.
You can just put in the private
IP into your application
and connect with that directly
to your Cloud SQL instance.
In order to access
that private IP,
you have to be on a VPC-native
Google Kubernetes Engine
cluster.
Now, this means that it
has to be a GKE cluster.
If you're using a
cluster off GCP,
you won't be able to connect.
Now, you may be thinking, if
it's so easy to use private IP,
do I still want
to use the proxy?
With the proxy, there's the
downside of the initial setup
being a little bit of a
hassle, but the upside
is you get strong IAM
authentication and strong
encryption for all the
data from your application.
For the proxy, the
advantage is you
don't have to worry
about the setup,
you can connect
directly via IP, but it
requires a VPC-native cluster.
So if you're connecting
from off-GKE,
you don't have that option.
And there's work authorization--
anyone on your cluster
could potentially
connect to your database.
Why is IAM so important?
Like, why do we push
the proxy so hard?
Well, the reason
is is that you can
use a service
account to represent
your entire application.
It gives you a one-to-one
mapping of permissions
to applications, which
makes it easy to manage.
If you decide that an
application no longer has
a need to access
the database, you
can simply remove the
permission and it no longer can,
even if changes to
the app are made.
Finally, it follows the
principle of least privilege.
The app only has the minimum
permissions that are needed,
which is a great
security advantage.
When you're running
the proxy as a service,
typically you do it as
a separate deployment
from your application.
So you can see on the left here,
we have our application pods
being deployed,
and on the right,
we have our proxy
pods being deployed.
And your application is going to
connect directly to the proxy,
and then your proxy is going
to route your connection
right to Cloud SQL.
One of the downsides
to this is the traffic
between your application
and proxy is not
encrypted by default. The proxy
doesn't offer any encryption
on the client side, it only
encrypts the traffic coming out
before it gets
connected to Cloud SQL.
Another disadvantage
is no authorization.
Anyone on your
cluster can connect
to the proxy, which means
anyone in your cluster
can connect to Cloud SQL.
This negates the advantage I was
talking about before with Cloud
SQL IAM authentication.
Another disadvantage is there
is a single point of failure.
If all of the applications
are using a single deployment
of the proxy to run, if
that deployment fails,
all of your applications are
no longer able to connect.
If something goes
wrong in the proxy
and it stops
operating correctly,
all of your applications fail
instead of just one instance.
Finally, another disadvantage
is the application and proxy
aren't necessarily running
in the same zone or region.
This adds additional latency
because now your application
has to jump first to
your proxy and then
to the Cloud SQL
instance, which could
be in an entirely different
region or zone, as well.
By keeping the application
and proxy together,
you can eliminate
this, meaning you only
have to worry about the latency
to the Cloud SQL instance.
This is why we recommend
running the proxy as a sidecar.
It's called a sidecar
pattern because if you
think of a motorcycle
with a sidecar,
it's attached to the side.
You still have your main
application here in the middle
and then you have the
Cloud SQL Proxy attached
to the side right here.
The application can connect
to the Cloud SQL Proxy
directly, which then
connects to Cloud SQL.
Because this is a pod,
it's an atomic unit,
meaning the application
and the Cloud SQL Proxy
are always together.
If the Cloud SQL Proxy
fails, the application
has also failed.
If the application fails,
the Cloud SQL Proxy
is still running
in the other pods.
It's authorized because the
Cloud SQL Proxy is inside
the same pod as the application.
Only the application
can access it.
And you don't have to worry
about other traffic accessing
a proxy that it's
not supposed to.
It's also isolated.
If the application fails
or the proxy fails,
you don't have to
worry about the rest
of your application going down.
It's just that pod that fails.
And finally, it's encrypted.
The minute the data leaves
your Cloud SQL Proxy,
it is encrypted and sent
to your Cloud SQL instance
before it's unencrypted.
This means you don't have to
worry about anybody potentially
listening in between your
application and your proxy.
OK, so you're convinced.
You want to use the Cloud SQL
Proxy in a sidecar, but how?
Let's talk about deploying
the proxy as a sidecar.
Again, there's two different
things you need to think about.
The first is you need to
decide how to pass credentials
into the proxy.
Once you've decided
that, you just
have to mount the
proxy as a sidecar
onto an existing application.
When you're passing
credentials, again, you
have a couple of
choices to make.
The first is workload identity.
This is where you can map a
Google Service Account, or GSA
for short, to a Kubernetes
Service Account,
or KSA for short.
The advantage of
this is you don't
have to worry about
managing any secrets.
But it is a GKE-only feature.
This means you'll have to
use a GKE cluster if you
want to take advantage of this.
If you're not
using a GKE cluster
or if you're operating
somewhere that
doesn't have workload
identity, you can still
use a service account key file.
This is where you have service
account credentials that
are stored in a JSON key file.
The downside is
you have to worry
about keeping track of that
JSON key file and rotating it,
but you are able to do this on
a standard Kubernetes instance.
So option 1, workload
identity for GKE.
If you look to the
left over there,
you'll see the application
of Cloud SQL Proxy.
What happens when you decide
to use application default
credentials is the client
library, including the Cloud
SQL Proxy, can reach out
to the metadata server.
This is true for both the
application and the proxy,
so you can use one
service account
to represent both things.
Once the Cloud SQL
Proxy makes that call,
it gets the token that it needs
to authorize with the instance
and uses it to make any
API calls necessary.
In order to set this up, the
first thing you'll need to do
is create a Kubernetes
Service Account.
This is a fairly
simple deploy and can
be a config.yaml that's stored
along with your application's
deployment.
Step two is you need to
bind your Google Service
Account to the Kubernetes
Service Account.
This is two steps.
It's one gcloud
command that specifies
which Google Service
Account you're using
and which Kubernetes
Service Account.
And then it's a
second step in kubectl
to connect to your
Kubernetes Service Account.
Finally, once you've
done the first two steps,
you need to add the
Kubernetes Service
Account to your application.
All you need to do is add
the service account name
that you specified
in the first step
and then bound in
the second step
to make sure that your
application uses it
when it's deployed next.
GKE will automatically handle
the metadata server for you,
as long as the option is
enabled on your cluster.
The second option you have is
the service account key file.
In this case, both the
application and the proxy
are going to load the
credentials from a file
and then use that credential
to generate the tokens needed
to make any API calls.
Step one is you have to
create a service account key.
So once you have your Google
Service Account created,
you can use a quick
gcloud command
to create a local key.json file.
Step two is you want to
turn the key into a secret.
Using kubectl, you can
create a generic secret
with whatever name
you prefer, and you
can use a specific file name and
load it from that local file.
In this case, we're using
service_account.json,
and we're loading
it from key.json,
which we created in step one.
Step 3 is we want to
mount as a volume.
What this is going to do is put
inside your pod's file system,
the file that you've
created as a secret
and make it accessible for
your application to access.
Once you've mounted
it as a file,
both the application
and the proxy
can read in and use it when
it's creating API calls.
Now, after you've
decided how you're
going to mount the
credentials, you just
need to mount the proxy
itself as a sidecar.
In this case, the proxy
runs in its own container,
and it shares a pod with
the main application.
This means it's really
easy to take your existing
configuration and add the
Cloud SQL Proxy to it.
You can see above we have a
pretty standard containers
deployment here, where you
have a list of containers
that you're using in
your Cloud SQL Proxy.
On this top half here, we have
things like the environment
variables you're using to
configure your database-- see,
this one is DB_USER, which
is created from a secret.
You also have the name
of the application
in the other configuration,
such as image or whatever
you've deciding to use.
On top of that, you can specify
the name of the Cloud SQL
Proxy, so you add as a separate
entry in your list here,
image cloudsql-docker/gce-proxy.
This is an image that
we maintain for you
so that you can use it.
Second, you just need to add the
command you want the Cloud SQL
Proxy to run.
So here we just have
Cloud SQL Proxy.
If you're using
private IP, you want
to enable the IP
addresses types flag
instead of equal to private,
and if you're using a service
account, you want to make sure
that you add the credential
file flag, as well, to tell
it where exactly that service
account is located.
Finally, you'll use
the instances flag
to pass in the name
of the instance
and the TCP port you
want it to listen to.
You can use whatever
TCP port you want,
or you can just default to the
standard for MySQL, Postgres,
or SQL Server.
If you're interested
in learning more,
here's some additional resources
you can take a look at.
The first is the Cloud SQL
Proxy, which is open-source,
written in Go,
available on GitHub.
The second is the Cloud
SQL JDBC socket factory.
This can be used by Java
users to connect directly
to your Cloud SQL
instance without using
the proxy in a similar manner.
If you're interested
in finding more,
please take a look at the repos.
And if you encounter any issues,
please open an issue on GitHub
and let us know.
Thanks for watching,
and have a great day.